(rock music)
- Me and Annie are gonna
try Singaporean McDonalds
for the very first time.
We didn't know what to order,
so we asked our friends over here,
Sylvia and Aiken.
- Hola
- So I think you should
try the Nasi Lemak burger.
This is basically
everything a Nasi Lemak is,
but without the rice.
- Oh, that's true.
- I'm gonna show you the
inside, which is beautiful.
- [Annie] Whoa! Do you see that steam?
- I actually, I'm a little worried. Ready?
It's actually really good.
Kind of confusing though.
- It's like slightly sour, which I like.
- It's the sauce, right?
What do you call that sauce?
- [Aiken] Sambal.
- Sambal Belacan.
Sambal Belacan basically is like
a very Asian tasting chili.
- It's so juicy. That's insane.
I think the best part of this is the egg.
- Yeah. Cucumber in a
burger is weird though.
- Our McSpicy is the best in the region
because it is the spiciest.
- [Annie] Oh no.
- We heard from our friends over here
that the spiciness can have an impact
on your digestive system in a strong way.
- Why do they feel so substantial here?
Like it kinda looks like
the promotional pictures.
(chuckles)
- Okay, you guys hyped
this up too much for me.
It's not that spicy.
- My tongue's on fire.
- Really? Does it get worse?
Yeah. It took like 20 seconds
to start feeling the spice.
Yeah. It's pretty good.
- It has a lot of flavor.
- I will, I'll tell you
tomorrow on how powerful
this dish was to my system.
- Maybe you shouldn't.
- Wait. Ice cream break.
There's a little hack,
apparently, here in Singapore.
If you order a McDelivery,
you order ice cream
so that they'll deliver
it to you faster, hmm.
Oh, that tastes exactly like the American
soft serve version.
(guitar music)
- There's nothing in the world like this.
- Very unique.
- Now I'm scared.
Today we go for the hot curry sauce.
Oh! That is a color.
- It does look like curry.
It's not bad.
- It's like sweet and sour
mixed with a curry powder
and it has an interesting aftertaste.
- It probably isn't my sauce of choice.
- Oh, my god. Where my Singaporeans at?
Steve and Annie don't like
curry sauce lah. (gasps)
(laughter)
We have the cheesy fries,
which is new in our menu
in our country.
I hope it's good.
(laughter)
- It looks a little wimpy.
Okay, let's just do this.
When you eat fries at McDonald's,
you gotta eat like 10 at a time.
- Oh.
- [Steven] Oh.
- [Annie] Perfect.
- Mmm.
- But it's good.
- Mm-hmm.
It's something you would
get at a hot dog stand.
- It does taste like a hot dog.
- The fries are the exact
same as they are in America.
You can't really go wrong
when you have cheese, bacon.
How can you mess that up?
I wanna see what they
think for the first time.
- Well, it's quite nice.
- Mm.
- Right, ordinarily, you
would just eat this part
and they wouldn't do with
the rest that has nothing.
- I did not know what to expect.
I thought it would be the same.
It actually was better to do here.
- Everything had a
slight Asian flair to it.
- An Asian flair in an actually Asian way.
Mm.
(upbeat guitar and violin music)